So I'm going to talk about a much smaller trial, phase one clinical trial, looking at
BFR-Cartesal therapy for B-cell non-herting lymphoma.
All the data show here are patients treated at City of Hope.
So just, I think we probably, most of us know that, no doubt, that Cartesal has already
resulted in landscape changes in how we treat patients with aggressive B-cell lymphoma.
From ZOMA 7, we know there's overall survival benefits, and PFS is also outperformed the
standard care at the time, salvage chemo plus transplant.
So PFS is 42%.
This is with a median for about four years.
That means that more than 50% of patients still will not have a durable remission, and
there's still room to go for us how to manage those patients.
And the main reason for those patients who did not survive after four years or they
procrastinated.
The cause of death is really progression of disease.
So one of the major resistance mechanisms for this CAR to fail is really antigen loss
or antigen down-modulation.
So once you have the CAR, it could persist, but if the antigen is not there, then the
CAR wouldn't work.
Now, there are many different approaches to get around this, make your CAR more potent
by adding a cytokine or other immune modulator, or as we learned about, dual targeting, so
multi-agent targeting.
So if you can't do multi-agent targeting, then it's really difficult to really get around
one antigen loss.
But there's another way to think about this, is what about an alternative antigen target,
a target that it'll be more difficult for the tumor cell to down-regulate or to lose?
So the molecule that we are interested in is called BAF-R.
BAF-R is a receptor that once it's upon binding with BAF, BAF actually binds to BAF-R, BCMA,
and then BF-R.
It's a receptor.
So BAF-R's main function in B cell development is B cell maturation, differentiation, and
also, more importantly, it delivers a survival signal.
And the BAF-R expression on the right side is on the top line.
So it's not really, it doesn't start with a pre-pro-B cell stage.
It gets to the immature transition of B cells and all the way into the cell becoming plasma
cells.
So it's a very short duration.
But it is a B cell delinquent marker.
And in tumor cells, the mental cell lymphoma cells, or lymphoblastic leukemia cells, BAF-R
is actually also required for tumor survival.
And we look at BAF-R expression on the abnormal lymphoid cells, that is, the mental cell lymphoma,
CLL, DLB cell, follicular, and marginal zone.
So it's pretty broadly expressed.
And we have done research.
Now, we demonstrated that.
When you have a B cell delinquent marker, there is a B cell delinquent marker.
And if you have a B cell delinquent marker, there is a B cell delinquent marker.
And in leukemia cells or lymphoma cells that are deficient in CD19, they still preserve
their BAF-R expression.
And here's just one preclinical study demonstrating that the same vector, different target, BAF-R,
or CD19, in this setting, the BAF-R CAR-T really outperforms the CD19 CAR-T's activities
in the tumor model.
And it's not because of antigen density, because the BAF-R expression level is much lower than
CD19 on these target cells.
So based on this, Larry Quagg has said, "I'm not sure if this is true."
Larry Quagg has said, "I hope we design a BAF-R CAR-T together with our CAR-T group's
effort."
So it's based on the antibody that derived from his research laboratory.
So we designed a phase one clinical trial to test these CAR-Ts in the patient with B
cells.
Now, host cell lymphoma, they need to have BAF-R expression either based on flow or based
on HC, and this assay was developed as a companion assay, and it's pretty standard.
on CAR-T treatment schema here. And here I'm showing the patient characteristics from eight
patients. So we had treated nine patients there, but there are some data not available. Therefore,
I'm only showing some results from first eight patients. And the first three patients received
15 million dose level one, and then you escalated to 200 million CAR-T dose. So six patients were
treated at the dose level two. And look at all those patients, most of them are mental cell
lymphoma patients. One patient has T cell history, B cell lymphoma, 19 and 20 negative.
5.8 patients already have prior signaling in CAR-T cell treatment. And four of the MCR patients
had TP3 mutation. So I hope you agree with me, this is not a very easy patient population to
treat. So we, you know, the data actually look pretty safe in this patient. At most,
patient will have a great one second release syndrome. Patient used to, you know, either they
get tocilizumab, no one gets any dexamethasone and result within just a few days. And ICANs only
occur in two out of eight patients, all in dose level one, and that's around a day, and no one
needed any intervention. And here's the clinical efficacy. All the patients, you know, seven out
of seven first treated patients received a complete remission, and they
continued staying remission. The one that being remission for more than three years is the top,
the first patient. So looking at the CAR-T expansion, so all patients now had
pretty high levels of CAR-T expansion. And the peak of expansion is actually in the second week
of the CAR-T infusion. And this is supported by both by flow cytometry study and also WPIE.
And this is like I throw in there, just we have now CD19 CAR-T expansion data from two of the
patients who had prior CD19 CAR-Ts compared. So compared to CD19 CAR-T expansion versus the
by far CAR-T expansion over time, they clearly by far CAR-T is expanding much higher and also
peak level is also much higher. And this is a study we used to look at the manufacturing
products activities from all the first six patients. All patients had complete remission,
and based on this polyfunctional strength index, which is really simultaneously looking at
cytokine production, looking at proliferation, and looking at CAR-T, you know, the product's
performance. Now, all six products has great performance. And I'm going to have a minute.
So this is a patient who had multiple lines of prior therapy, around 10 lines of prior therapy,
mental cell lymphoma. Now, his treatment course really is like telling a story how we manage
mental cell lymphoma over the years. The patient had, you know, by specific patient had row one
rectal cells. Actually, the first one who got rectal cells, CTL-HOLD, but unfortunately
didn't stay in remission long enough. So the patient was enrolled into the study. He actually
tolerated the treatment really well. And we look at the bone marrows. Now, after the post-CAR-T
treatment, the one on the right lower panel, now all the by far positive cells were gone.
And we look at this, the UMAP, looking at different populations over time. Now, the bright green one
here, the CAR-T cells, you see the CAR-T cell continue to expand throughout the time. You know,
it really gets out around day nine and continues through day 28. And there are also a minor
population of CD4 CAR-Ts there. And so the plan for this study is we already decided to use 200
milling as the RP2D instead of further escalate to those level three. And this study now becoming
a multi-center study for our phase two expansion cohort. And in addition,
CAR-T is also evaluated in a phase one clinical trial for a patient with beta-ALL. Thank you.